hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to case animatronics
now apparently we have the key card in
our inventory but I don't know where Oh
hmm hey buddy how's it going so I don't
know where it goes now there's a key
card thing to look at in bed oh I lost
me okay so good thing it's really really
not smart and full of dumb otherwise I
would have been dead there okay so
obviously I can't go through here or
else it'll be penny'll come after me so
I can't leave even though I probably
have the authorization to do so game
logic is that cheese but game logic game
logic dictates it was luck with the
kicker but I have a key card well that's
not what I wanted so nice why peace whoa
I don't know how to spoil what nope okay
so that's not gonna work so there's got
to be another door with a key card
somewhere around here and I'm gonna find
it I'll be back there we go got it okay
this is the one who's in here why are we
in here why are we in here is there more
story done unfold untold whatever the
word is I don't really care what the
hell happened oh no no hide what time
for hide it's just gonna kill me anyway
we gotta go we gotta go
oh he's coming hmm where do we go turn
it in a little now of course it's closed
what you mean to say is locked okay
damnit I need another key card [ __ ] it's
gotta be something here there's got to
be something anything why did I go in
this room what's that over there
oh wait didn't I need this well oh good
we have a friend active oh hey
Oh sick bastard a giant cat what else
can you think of I should avoid the
ventilation tubes yeah Prabha if I got
back with Izzie yeah I remember the
dosage Ben's a god oh god damnit
holobyte buzzes now who's gonna pop down
right in the same room that I was a load
of ass so I gotta find Ben's room now
I've got where was Ben's room Ben's room
in here no I think Ben's room was in the
other part of the office wasn't it we're
here somewhere ooh where do I look up in
here
charger no I feel like I would have
known about this and this this tablet
did not last long enough okay so I gotta
find without dying dogs in here huh what
did why and how hmm okay this isn't
Ben's room at all
this isn't Ben's room at all how do I
get two pens room oh hello more story I
read a group leader has given us a task
everybody must draw an unusual object or
character for Halloween she said that
she wanted our group to participate in
an exhibit unlike any other I mean who
recalled those animatronic philippi 300
grow okay where are you that's a good
sound but where are you
[ __ ] I've got a lot to wile [ __ ] [ __ ]
well I got Aten oh [ __ ] well that ain't
good just gonna go for it get a gun for
it block is broke [ __ ]
Oh what hit Glocks from the evidence
storage could solve the problem the big
blocks think I'm starting to understand
where these giant toys came from
they were evidence from one of the cases
that explains a lot
huh that's awfully a convenient
explanation I'm just gonna go for it hmm
we're near oh [ __ ] you gonna hide okay
let me hide under I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead
where is he crazy he must be down that
way so I get it I gotta stay in here I
gotta wait until he goes by
I got some in my throat I gotta make a
lot of mouth sounds I think they went
away I I'm pretty sure about it now that
I think about I'm pretty sure they're
gone huh he was not gone what the fack
it was gone ah come on come on come on
go go go run faster closed door fine
under the desk
[ __ ] off ah sucks dick stop don't do
that I'm on edge this is the evidence
storage room is it not what is this in
the state of Colorado and the city
aurora according to witnesses at 1 a.m.
and unidentified gunmen entered the
house and threatened the family
neighbors and passerby called the police
reporting a lot of noise from the house
a police officer arrived at the scene
turned out to be a first call during the
struggle a woman died and the man was
wounded the owner of the house is
currently hospitalized in a coma the
criminal managed to escape and even
though the police officer did not
sustain any injuries he didn't undergo
psychological evaluation the police
refused to comment on the case so what
does that have to do with this I can
only assume that it's all related
somehow I just find out how that might
have been my first case and maybe I
botched it up and that's why this guy's
mad at me he was robbed by someone I
respond to the scene and someone got
injured his wife got killed what
happened
[ __ ]
okay yeah go that way dick stupid stupid
dick [ __ ] don't turn around don't turn
around don't go in there
I need to go in there oh [ __ ] it's not
going in there uh no [ __ ] do I do is it
going in there okay he's going in there
okay
give me oh that's bad as that loss is
broken the pick locks from the evidence
storage could solve the problem soon
how did Emma starting to understand
where these giant toys key after me
[ __ ] god this is hard now that is two of
them it's like an obscenely difficult
just to get around from A to B Apple it
is happening go through the fence well
in that what is that was that a cat
purring Jesus okay try the scale oh [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god damn and I'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
am i [ __ ] my not [ __ ] mmm somehow AM
no [ __ ] okay all right I don't know how
uh okay so in here there we go let's try
to open the door okay so hopefully that
saved it so hopefully Jesus I thought I
was dead but now am live gotta get back
oh how did I close this door oh oh
cutscene oh oh no I can't do anything I
can't see that that's just great
what do you mean this is great we went
around he went the wrong way
[ __ ] me god damn it
good thing it's saved I saw the save
icon it better give me that goddamn
check point okay so that's good oh come
on
how and why and how again I thought that
was this random chance that it was there
last time
wow I'm dying a lot I apologize off
[ __ ] go in there go in there and then
in it okay
they don't know I'm here how would they
it's a secret
no one knows right man I'm sorry I've
made no progress yet okay so I just
gotta wait for them to get out of here
and then I'll be free and clear but for
some reason they're adamant about being
all up in my book they're like walking
in tandem thankfully farther away though
okay so this should be good should be
clear should be clear it's like there we
go
got it okay I'm in I'm in I'm in close
the door
lines okay we're good so in here there
should be it's weird
know the Chargers huh let's see what's
on the computer screen let's see yeah or
duck straight underneath it the virus
what what is it is it a game so you want
me to go through it shut up
now the charger is working you can
launch the tablet sure that's how that
works that's how technology works
everybody
apparently all right so so it's charging
but it's not done yet what's in here why
are there either like locks on this oh
hello
that looks important like it's the
keycard for some door gym your huh well
I bet I know what door it is I don't
know if I oh hey how's it going friend
you coming straight for me all the way
from you to me well let me get under
here first time I've actually used this
well it didn't sound good okay
everything's gonna be a-okay so long as
he gets the [ __ ] out of here and then I
can go unlock the other key card but I
think I think because this was was read
I think I remember seeing a red
something or other over beyond the door
that I already opened with the key card
I think it's the door beyond that which
opens again okay I don't know which way
he went
hopefully out but yeah I think okay so
through Oh Vince what do you want me to
remember you said I took everything from
you I don't know I thought whose call I
knew I remember it the complete failure
even for a rookie like me who just
graduated from the Academy Scott his
wife and kid were killed and Scott ended
up in intensive care why did he refuse
to speak with me is because I didn't
catch the killer
this is silly he only made it worse your
way he clearly blames me for what
happened
oh damn cat now whoa oh no oh no oh no
no no no no no yes uh don't purr at me
don't be purring I don't like that
wasn't me
here shoo shoo shoo here get scared of a
phone yeah here
okay I didn't see what was happening
I guess the flashlight doesn't really
bother him I don't imagine it does
anyway I'll answer that phone yes I will
let me read this first in 1977 there was
only one company to use the animatronic
for amusement children while the
companies use them for movies which is
very cool I remember when I went to the
restaurant so this is a look so real at
what if they could walk yes sure the
fever's dream alive bishop prom oh yeah
me at that live boy good mouse for my
cat I like playing with you Thanks
there's a card and the safe behind you
it is the key to the interrogation room
okay mouse deserves a piece of cheese do
try to stay alive until 3 o'clock in the
morning if you make it you'll get the
key survive in this hell until 3:00 a.m.
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] son of a bench
crap ventilation system is on and off
the ventilation I really need to find a
way to reset the ventilation at the
control room Oh sick bastard obviously
wants me to suffer and my flashlight is
dead it's perma dead okay so that means
that I'm on my own
surviving alone but I'm not gonna do it
now I'm gonna do that in the next
episode so thank you everybody so much
for watching sorry about all the death
I'm very bad apparently but I'll get
good later so thanks again and as always
I'll see you in the next video bye bye